i know that me as an individual i only
really have 15 minutes of fame or maybe
a few years at best in the limelight
what are the things that i can do to
diversify away from me as an individual
so that the business that i make has
more longevity than just whether people
care about my personal life i have
stumbled into this ridiculously
incredible career we're making stupidly
large amounts of money how do i continue
to live that kind of life where i'm just
spending my time reading writing and
teaching turns out that it's not just my
experience there are all sorts of kind
of scientific studies backing this up
this idea that certain types of work is
energizing and certain types of work is
depleting just like you know certain
types of people you hang out with are
energizing and certain types of people
just completely drain your energy that's
the same thing happens with work now one
solution to that conundrum is oh well
just quit your job and follow your
passion because that will energize you
but i think that's the wrong solution i
think the right solution is
hey friends welcome back to deep dive if
you're new here my name is ali and in
each episode i normally chat to
entrepreneurs authors creators and other
inspiring people about how they got to
where they are and the strategies and
tools that can help us all along our
shared journey of trying to live our
best lives but this is an episode in the
offseason we have just wrapped up season
two of the podcast and we have not yet
started season three and so we're doing
this little bit of an episode uh which
lots of you have requested as a q a
where angus one of my team members
actually interviews me and it's kind of
a life and business update to kind of
show you where we are with this creative
printer business that we're running and
how things are going uh and the
challenges that we're facing along the
way as some of you might know anger
started working for me about two years
ago and he started off as a part-time
writer he actually cold emailed me out
of the blue and said hey i want to join
your team as a writer and he started off
working with me like one project at a
time and then one day a week then two
days a week then four days a week and
now he has become our general manager
integrator director of operations
whatever you want to call it and he's
basically my right-hand man he basically
runs the entire business side of things
so that i can have my own time freed up
to focus on the creative side which is
awesome and now the running joke is that
angus works eight days a week anyway in
this conversation we talk about things
like how we got to where we are right
now how we're thinking about the
business and the podcast and the youtube
channel and all the other stuff that
we're doing in the book how we've ended
up with a team of 18 people and what
that's like i'm gonna stop talking now i
hope you enjoy this episode
talking about like the studio though and
the team
is this what you expected so it was kind
of weird moving to the studio moving
moving to london and suddenly like
starting this whole
actually building a physical business
with like almost like a corporate
structure around it because
a i would have assumed that everything
has to be remote weirdly um and i would
have assumed that like
how does a
business that fundamentally just makes
youtube makes youtube videos why does
that need so many people but it's been
fun
and it's nice having the space and the
space is cool and i do enjoy coming to
work every day
which is nice and it's really nice not
having camera equipment in my own flat
just like clogging everything up and
like wires all around the floor now we
have those all around the studio which
is you know a better place for them to
be than at home
but overall pretty solid experience i
would say there's people that kind of
question why you need so many people to
to run a youtube channel
does that ever make you question
the the size of the team in the business
and the direction you're going it does
yeah it often does um you know sometimes
i see like videos of graham stefan
reacting to some of the videos that i've
made he's like he's got 18 people on his
team what the hell are you doing with 18
people on your team um similarly we've
got other friends you know aaron and
many mr who's the boss who has a team of
like three people and like 10 million
subscribers so part of me thinks that
like
we have an 18 a team of 18 people
are we
like on the surface that seems a bit
much for quote just making youtube
videos but
then i stop and think about it i think
like if you want to grow a business
beyond a certain size i think if you
want to for me as the
kind of business owner
i i only really want to do the things
that i really enjoy doing and that i'm
really good at
and there's a bunch of stuff that moves
the business forward in terms of
helping add value to people's lives and
increasing our revenues which is not in
that category of things that i love
doing and things i'm great at
and so the next question becomes okay
cool let's hire people to do that thing
and as you know like being sort of
official employee number one but like
employee number two in in the team
like with with a small team
then
everyone is kind of doing a little bit
of everything and there's a bit of
delegation and then as we realize that
oh things are growing we want to do this
other thing and this other thing and
this other thing we very quickly run
into capacity issues where it's actually
more than two people's full-time jobs to
be able to do all the stuff that we want
to do if we're thinking courses are
doing really well why don't we release a
course every quarter it's actually quite
a lot of work putting course together
and we think the channel is doing really
well let's double our output of videos
that's actually quite a lot of work if
we're thinking let's launch a podcast
that's quite a lot of work there's a lot
of stuff
that um happens as you add more and more
lines to a business
and i think most creative businesses
with significantly smaller teams they
are just making youtube videos whereas
for us um you know youtube videos
courses podcast or youtuber academy
which is its own like ridiculously sort
of high kind of takes a lot of work to
run a six week live cohort three or four
times a year
um writing the book doing all the social
media stuff doing all the website stuff
there's quite a lot to do and even now
even with a team of 18 people it still
feels as if we're running into capacity
issues
so i think well i think what we're
trying to do here is
yeah 18 people is actually probably too
few for that yes it's not just youtube
videos i think that's a good point
because
you have them very well in terms of
pivoting and reinvesting in the team and
things like that i guess that's just
things that we have we see in other
creators who are successful like mr
beast and that kind of thing is that
reinvestment into the business which
some creators just don't seem to want to
do or have fearful about doing which
might limit their
growth
yeah it's it's interesting and you know
thinking back to where where when i
joined as you said employee number two
it was just like three of us really just
making youtube videos and that was fine
when skillshare courses started to come
on and other stuff come on then that's
when
team is kind of needed because you reach
that capacity yeah i think at every
stage it was about thinking like
what is like where is the bottleneck at
this stage like
um
what
what's an area which if we had more
capacity we would be able to do more
stuff yeah
or to do stuff better and so initially
it was a case of kind of you
christian was brought on initially as a
sort of head of content plus editor so
someone who could help edit videos but
also you could help ideate and help
maybe write stuff and help kind of maybe
repurpose articles for the website um
and then you sent me a cold email being
like can i join as a writer and i was
like oh great well i actually need
someone to help me write videos because
i have all these videos video ideas i
want to do but i physically don't have
the time to research and write them all
myself and so some of the videos you did
you know is coffee good for you the
journal club stuff did you study with it
without music i think that there were a
few things here and there
then i did editing as well oh then i was
editing as well then you were editing
some stuff as well and then it was like
oh let's make a skillshare class let's
make another one this cautious courses
thing is doing well let's do more of
this kind of stuff and elizabeth came on
as a kind of personal assistant
part-time personal assistant fairly
accidentally and then when we started
our youtuber academy at that point
was that still when there was still
still just four of us four of us in the
business elizabeth very part-time i had
just quit my job as a doctor then then
we were thinking okay this youtuber
academy took a lot of work what if we
like where where is the bottleneck now
and the bottleneck ended up being again
in terms of like idea generation and
writing for the youtube channel and also
repurposing for social media on the
website so we brought in gareth and
jacob and then we did some you know more
and more stuff happened there was
another bottleneck so at each at each
bottleneck juncture is like okay where
do we have a capacity issue and could we
potentially hire to fill that capacity
issue
and i think this is something that we
sort of did very accidentally over time
without really having a hiring process
without knowing anything about hiring
but over the last two years of slowly
building up the team to 18 people now i
think we've learned quite a lot along
the way yeah and it was probably that
that youtuber academy moment that
because we were four people for about
eight months it was that youtube academy
moment and then the fact that we
realized that that worked and we were
going to do it again yeah which then
raised the capacity issues around where
he's going to write the videos then if
angus is helping doing the academy and
yeah all of that in terms of having
having enough time when you mentioned
when you brought me on you didn't have
enough time because you were still a
doctor and that kind of thing it's now
like six to eight months since you left
medicine how
officially how do you feel now having
made that decision now that you're kind
of full-time being an entrepreneur and
hopefully an author yeah i feel pretty
good about it i think one of the nice
things about medicine is that it gives
you a very certain career path and one
of the
less nice things about this is that it
feels very uncertain but i think over
time i've become embracing of that
uncertainty and you know we were having
a conversation with our mutual coach liz
wright earlier today and i was thinking
that like one of my biggest fears is
kind of slowly losing irrelevancy slowly
losing relevancy over time and one thing
that you and and and she said which was
very valid is that like you know
we we've managed to do this several
times already like we've changed
directions we've built you know even
before this youtube stuff i'd built a
business helping people get into med
school which was pretty profitable and
did pretty well like building businesses
and creating content these these are all
skills and i think in the past i had
under-appreciated the value of those
skills whereas over time every realize
the value of the skills realized that
actually uncertainty is good everyone
has uncertainty in their lives whether
you're an entrepreneur or an employee in
any kind of capacity there's always a
level of uncertainty and being embracing
of that
and recognizing that hey if the winds
change then the winds change and that's
okay
um i do kind of feel that we have a sort
of uh kind of like an athlete does like
you have
kind of the proverbial 15 minutes of
fame
and so a how do you capitalize on that
as much as possible
um recognizing that hey this this ain't
gonna last forever let me make hay while
the sun shines and
you know what we're doing right now
trying to make loads of money while
trying to help people and what i'm doing
kind of behind the scenes reinvesting
that into real estate and into other
asset classes that are decoupled from
the internet
um but at the same time thinking okay
given that i know that me as an
individual i only really have 15 minutes
of fame or maybe a few years at best in
the limelight what are the things that i
can do to diversify away from me as an
individual so that the business that i
make is sort of
has more longevity than just whether
people care about my personal life and i
think this is some of the one of the
things that like a lot of lifestyle type
youtubers have struggled with where you
grow big initially because you're a
lifestyle type youtuber and then the
audience grows up and they realize that
they don't really care about the
lifestyle you make up beauty type
content whatever the case might be and
then the views start to decline and if
there isn't a solid business built
around that and it's all based on
youtube adsense and brand deals and
stuff like that
it's a it's a very fragile business that
i think doesn't really stand the test of
time so everything that i've been trying
to do is just really thinking like in a
way being very very risk-averse it's
like i've stumbled into this
ridiculously incredible career where i
can do whatever i want i can i have the
freedom to learn stuff and teach stuff
on my own terms or making stupidly large
amounts of money how do i continue to
live that kind of life um where i'm just
spending my time reading writing and
teaching and what does the business look
like to support those activities
you mentioned a word like career do you
see
like how do you how do you define what
you do at the moment as a career i don't
really think of it as a career i i don't
really use the word career when i think
of my own life okay i think career is in
a way an anachronism of like oh i have a
career as a banker that's kind of why i
picked up on it it's like it feels
yeah i kind of feel like i kind of felt
it it kind of felt a bit off using using
the word career um i just kind of view
all of this as like my life and part of
my life is quote work i don't even think
of it as work like even when i said the
phrase i enjoyed going to work each
morning it's like i really don't think
of it as going to work it really does
feel like an extension of my my life
and i think i think for me that
works because i am the sort of business
owner and the founder i wonder what's
what's it like for you
oh this doesn't feel like work okay but
i love it do you
generally i'm not saying that's on
camera but i guess like do you do do you
see it
as i do as like oh there's just an
example in my life or is it like
do you consider it that oh this is the
thing that i do for work
good question
i think as
as we've discussed at length and you've
pointed out to me at length
the the work does become my life
probably too too much but that is more
about my personal social life than
anything else um
but i i don't
i've never felt like this is a chore
i see it as a as a job because it pays a
salary every month yep therefore it by
that strip by that definition it is work
yeah but
it's
fun it's enjoyable and i don't as i said
i've never come in to this office for
example since we've been here since
october and even before then when we're
in wework and even before then when we
were working from home during the
pandemic i never got up thinking oh god
i've gotta write another script for ali
today well i've gotta write i've gotta
go and
i don't know take all these bins out for
it or wherever else i've done yeah like
i've never felt like that and so it's
never felt like i've never worked in a
corporate role but i would imagine it's
never felt like
that going in and clocking in at nine
o'clock clocking out at five o'clock
it's never felt
like that yeah so i wonder if like we
were we were looking at the results of
our employee survey for this quarter
earlier earlier today and a bunch of
people basically saying that they really
struggle with the work-life balance
and i found that baffling because i'm
like oh why are people struggling with
work-life balance like i really couldn't
give a
you know less of a [ __ ] about when
people come in and when people work and
whether people work and that's that's
like we've got a team now that's why we
need to consider it more no when we were
working together like two of us three of
us four of us whatever it was like oh
we're all missed together we're kind of
making this work and it's good
you know how it's going to last it's not
really a business really yet because
it's only four of us really
but now it's like a team
those kind of things matter yeah but
yeah but i guess my point was that like
because i don't view it as work and
because you clearly don't view it as
work it's very easy for us to just be
here all the time
and for other people in the team who
have maybe a healthier relationship with
a job as being a job yes which which you
know as it as it well should be because
it is just a job at the end of the day
um i think
probably
i don't know i need to be more mindful
of hey this actually is a job and oh i'm
going to take time off and in my time
off i'm not going to check slack and i'm
not going to
go on zoom calls and stuff because i
guess like when you were
when you're a doctor you didn't like
ring up the hospital on your days off
going
what's happening guys
you know you forgot about it until you
went in the next day yeah although
having said that unless you're uncool if
you're if you're for example the
consultant and you're responsible for
the ward then even on their days on the
days off they'd be like messaging like
hey i need to take a support how's my
patient doing so i think there is an
element of like that yeah when you have
that level of ownership you kind of feel
like it's your baby if you're like i
don't want to leave my baby alone with
these strangers for a while like i want
to make sure baby's doing all right give
it given that kind of approach to
not
seeing it as a career
and seeing it just as your extension of
your
of your life where do you kind of
see it going obviously writing a book at
the moment is that the direction you
want to take things is it more seeing
how far the youtube thing will go
where do you see the next three to five
years
panning out
so the first thing to say is i have no
idea like who can predict the future but
if i think you know
when we do our like i kind of vision
building for the business and thinking
about what does the three-year picture
look like what i think is like you know
the book is out um the book does really
well people really like book i'm working
on a second book because i do like the
idea of writing and sharing knowledge in
that kind of way the youtube channel is
continuing to do well the podcast is
continuing to do well we have a slightly
bigger team not a significantly bigger
team but maybe a slightly bigger team we
maybe have a studio in london that has
multiple filming sets so maybe a set for
youtubers set for podcast are set for
something else
our students for our youtuber academy
become our kind of students for life and
maybe once a week we host a sort of
uh
weekly lunch where anyone who's ever
been a student of ours can rock up to
the office studio and we'll buy them
lunch and we just hang out and making
almost this community of other like
creator uh creator printers creator
entrepreneurs i like
i'm kind of imagining that we have a
sort of research team that is
you know because ultimately what we're
about is
is really trying to kind of help people
live their best life in the field of
personal development so having a
research team that's constantly you know
subscribed to all of the latest like
scientific journals you know the
psychology journals and sociology
journals and like the health journals
and stuff to figure out are there any
interesting new studies that have come
out recently could we maybe interview
the academic who's written this new book
that's out recently how do we
as a business
basically
um
document and take what other people are
doing in the realm of personal
development and how do we package it up
and give it more airtime and present it
to a more mainstream audience maybe i i
i what i kind of imagine is that i spend
one of my days hanging out with the team
some you know a few hours of the
researchers a few hours with our writing
team who are like
you know looking through a script of
like oh we've you know there's this
really cool book that i don't know david
sinclair has written on lifespan 2.0 and
we're going to do a video where we've
interviewed him for the podcast and
we're summarizing the insights from this
book so that more people can
understand
how to live until the age of 150 and we
have this genuine expert on the topic
who's actually blending his expertise
and credibility to the video that we're
gonna make
and we'll encourage people to buy the
book and stuff so he's happy because
he's getting more book sales and more
exposure we're happy because our youtube
channel is doing well everyone's happy
because they're getting this knowledge
that feels pretty cool i sort of imagine
myself maybe spending one day a week
doing that team stuff one day a week
filming maybe half to one day a week
recording a podcast and the rest of that
time is fairly free to kind of reading
writing continue continuing to come up
with ideas and just generally living
life on on my own terms that's sort of
what i imagined the three-year kind of
horizon looking like in terms of the
business side of things you still
imagine it being
the sort of courses paid content funding
a much larger delivery of free content
to a wider audience as possible yeah so
i often say that if we had unlimited
money we wouldn't bother making any
courses we would just put everything out
there for free
but
i mean we need to have a profitable
business business and the way i think of
it is like 9911. 99 of our content is
free and one percent of our accordion or
or our content is paid and that is and
that appeals to one percent of our
audience and if we can fund the entire
business of producing tons and tons of
really good free content off the back of
selling courses to over one percent then
that feels like a pretty sustainable
business model for the long term and i
guess you know over the past year we've
read tons of different business books
and things like that but that whole
model and that thing you've just
outlined for three to five years
whatever it was i feel still feels very
almost like new and very creative
focused creativepreneur focused um so
what
do you think that kind of business model
is going to be replicated across other
people or do you think this is unique to
to our business or is it somewhere where
you know other people can start to move
in that direction moving forward yeah i
don't think it's particularly unique i
think people have been doing this for
kind of
probably
i mean i guess
this is basically what tony robbins does
and has been doing since like the 1960s
or whatever whenever whenever he first
came onto the scene create creating
content for a mass audience through his
books and his audio tapes and stuff back
in the day and then selling a high price
to retreats and stuff yeah and then that
funds his whole business and he's
changed like millions if not tens of
millions of lives all around the world
through his content and obviously some
people will be like oh my god tony
robbins want to say a snake or salesman
but there's always going to be people
like that but for the people who are in
his core audiences the the people that
he's targeting with this stuff he's had
an enormous impact so i think this sort
of business has been around forever i
say forever for at least like 70 years
at this point 60 years at this point
and as content platforms come on come on
the scene i think there's always going
to be a case for like
some way of distributing stuff for free
to the masses and then some way of
monetizing that on the back end to a
smaller number of that audience and so
this sort of free content
um helps drive traffic to paid content
paid content helps drive revenue to the
business produce more free content and
you get this sort of free content and
paid content flywheel so what's always
interesting about
you and kind of your ambitions is with
that
outline
why is it that you don't i kind of
already know the answer to this but like
why is it that you don't want to build a
media company akin to garyvee or
maybe not that big but like a bigger
media company around your name and your
brand why is it that you want to keep it
as
kind of as big as it needs to be i think
you've said in the past yeah so the
thing with garyvee is gary has like 25
people on his team that's not radically
different to ours garyvee has like a
whole like thousand people person
company which does like
social media consulting and advertising
for clients but yeah that's kind of the
the larger garyvee empire then is what i
was kind of referring to yeah so i think
for me the thing that i fundamentally
care about is teaching yeah and i have
zero interest in running an advertising
agency
probably could but like the thought of
running i don't know a social chain or a
vaynerx or whatever these companies are
it's just like it does not excite me at
all whereas the thought of actually just
being able to be a teacher ultimately at
the end of the day where i can learn
stuff that i find interesting i can
teach stuff that i find interesting and
i can hopefully help people and to be
stupidly profitable at the same at the
same time with a team to support those
functions that is the thing that filled
me with excitement and that's like when
i think of
you know i sometimes think of the
question that if i won the euro millions
and had like 100 million in the bank
what would i do with my with my life
and i think it's probably the same stuff
that i do now i wouldn't make courses
granted because the only reason we do
that kind of broadly is to make money
that funds the free content but i still
would be making youtube videos i'd still
be wanting to write books and still be
wanting to do loads of reading and
that's basically why i spend my time
doing it the courses are still teaching
right the courses are still teaching i
guess i would like you know we're
working on a course about camera
confidence we're working a course for
creatorpreneurs i would just show all
that on youtube for free rather than
charge people for it even though in the
interest of the business those courses
are going to be very good of course yeah
they're going to be sick but if we
didn't need to make money to fund the
business they'd just go online for free
so if anyone anyone any very wealthy
funders want to uh listening to this and
want all of our stuff to be free forever
if someone if so if someone say if
someone gave us funding and said you
know just put everything online for free
forever i'd be like sick this is
yeah let's do it that'd be interesting
interesting proposition very new i don't
think i've ever seen anyone else do that
before very novel even though
there are other brands out there like
creator now who have source funding i
know that they're moving towards a very
different business to what we want to
create but
there is uh funding going into creative
businesses now which i don't know
whether that was the case five ten years
ago yeah probably not i think there were
always like you know these like maker
studios and these content companies with
loads of funding behind them who would
kind of present like represent a creator
and make them kind of make them blow up
and then monetize them up for brand
deals and stuff i think that's been a
thing for a while but yeah i think we're
in a new ish generation where
creator businesses are generating kind
of kind of seed funding series a funding
as if they were proper startups which in
which they are
so on the topic of the book how how is
that going
and
because it's been it's been a while
since uh probably anyone had any update
on it yeah um
what's sort of the the timeline now for
when that's coming out what the general
thesis is that kind of thing yeah so um
tentative publication date is probably
in january 2024 we are hoping to have a
decent draft of the manuscript done by
like july august this year
and so you know a lot of the last kind
of 12 months or so has been around
massaging the concept figuring out what
what do we actually want to say and i
think we're now pretty close to having
worked out what we want to say and so
the research is underway some of the
writing is underway
and yeah basically it's a book about
productivity but the core thesis is that
you know the secret to
sustainable productivity meaningful
productivity is to find ways to harness
energy from the work that you're doing
so that it energizes you rather than
exhausts you and if you can do that then
all the productivity stuff kind of takes
care of itself you don't need to worry
about hacks and to-do list management
and stuff all that all that stuff works
but generally when people come to me and
ask for advice around productivity
they're not saying i have 300 emails in
my inbox because i'm a law partner at
like some fancy law firm and i need a
method for inbox zero what they're
saying is i don't have the energy when i
get home from work or when i get home
from my university lectures i don't have
the energy to do the things i want to do
like start a business or start a youtube
channel or learn that language or even
don't even have the energy to hang out
with my friends and family in like an
appropriate way how do i get the energy
how do i get that motivation those tend
to be the issues people struggle with
how do i focus when i'm doing something
that i feel isn't really kind of um
particularly interesting and
so i think that's where this kind of
idea of energy and finding ways to
harness energy from the stuff that
you're doing anyway really really helps
so is that something that you've felt
over the last 10 15 years when you've
run businesses that you've or you've
never felt that
lack of energy yeah
essentially i i have felt like a lack of
energy but i have often
tried my best to find ways to make
whatever i'm doing more energizing
and i sort of accidentally found ways to
do that just through trial and error but
then through the research process for
the book when i really sat down with the
editor and stuff and figured out like
what is actually my thesis for
productivity
that was the thing that we kind of
landed like oh yeah it really is about
energy
and turns out that it's not just my
experience there are all sorts of kind
of scientific studies backing this up
this idea that certain types of work is
energizing and certain types of work is
depleting just like you know certain
types of people you hang out with are
energizing and certain types of people
just completely drain your energy that's
the same thing happens with work
now one solution to that conundrum is oh
well just quit your job and follow your
passion because that will energize you
but i think that's the wrong solution i
think the right solution is find ways to
make the thing whatever you're doing
more energizing find ways to make it
more interesting so that it energizes
you and if you've tried all the various
methods that we talk about in the book
and you still can't do it because it
really does suck at that point you can
think maybe i should quit my job but
until then there's a lot that we can do
within our control to
help
a be more productive but also have more
energy at the end of the workday which
we can then use on our dreams or our
passions or on just being more present
with our friends and family by the way i
wanted to take a quick break from the
podcast to say that if you like the
sound of this book then i would love it
if you could sign up to my book email
newsletter it's completely free and
every two weeks i just send a quick
email with a little update about what
we've been working on in the book me and
my team of researchers and writers and
like what interesting insights from the
world of productivity or like psychology
or behavioral economics we've discovered
that week or in that last two weeks that
we're trying to slowly figure out how to
incorporate into the book and how we can
incorporate it into our into our own
lives and in the book newsletter we also
often ask you the audience for stories
and input and
ideas on the concepts that we're sharing
and over time i think we've got about 25
000 people on that list right now and
it's great because every time we send
one out we get loads of people replying
with some really interesting stories and
a bunch of those stories are actually
going to feature in the book so if you
would like to share some stories that
would maybe get featured in the book
with credits to you of course or you
just want to see what the book journey
process has been like or if you want to
be kind of if you want to get up to date
on what these productivity hacks and
like life hacks are as they're hot off
the press then do please sign up to the
book newsletter that will be linked in
the video description and in the show
notes if you fancy following along and
like i said it is completely free and
you can unsubscribe at any time that you
like yeah i think i think the whole
advice of yeah just quit your job and
follow your passion it also is a bit
reductionist as well in terms of the
actual yeah maybe it works like a trust
fund but yeah most of us have to work
yeah exactly
what impact would you want that book to
have i don't like to think too much in
terms of like numbers
but if
there is like one person who reads the
book and and it kind of
changes their relationship with their
work where maybe before they were like
not really enjoying their job not really
enjoying the studies and like felt that
they were drained at the end of the
workday and couldn't really bring
themselves to have the energy or the
motivation to do the stuff they actually
wanted to do to live their best life if
they apply some of the stuff from the
book and they find it useful then
what i'd love for is that they get to
the end of the workday feeling actually
energized like as if they've got some
energy left in the tank and then they
can use the energy and whatever they
want and you know i love it when people
start youtube channels so if someone
were to email me afterwards and be like
hey i applied the concepts in the book
and you know it made me more productive
in my job it made me it made me enjoy my
job more but it also made me realize
that actually maybe maybe the job isn't
for me but you know it gave me the
energy to in the evenings start my i
don't know web design side hustle or
start my youtube channel and now i've
gotten to the point where i can go
part-time i can i can use that time to
spend more time with my friends and
family because i've built these streams
of passive income that would be like a
really cool result
but i am
what i'm trying to keep in mind is that
the impact of the book is outside of my
control and this is one of the things
we're going to talk about in the book
the idea of setting goals that are input
based for me i always find it
way more energizing to have a goal
that's fundamentally within my control
like i want to write the best book i can
or i want to write a book i'm proud of
rather than a book that's outside of my
control of like i want this book to have
this certain type kind of impact or i
want this book to hit the new york times
bestseller list so i do
it's
you know in a way a sort of double think
kind of situation where i know the kind
of impact i would like to have but i'm
not trying to think about it too hard
because i know that will deplete my
energy when it comes to actually
creating the thing
that makes sense that makes sense but
the point you made about you want it to
have an impact on how change people's
relationship with work kind of
interesting given what you said earlier
about your own relationship with work so
do you want more people to have
relationships to their work more akin to
what you do now
um not necessarily in terms of like
ownership in terms of like i feel like
this is an extension of my life and this
is my baby that's probably only really
confined to like entrepreneurs and like
general partners and stuff
but certainly this sort of relationship
where it's
a sense of
my work can be fun my work should
ideally be fun and there are things that
i can personally do to make it more fun
to make it more energizing
whereas i feel like
a lot of i don't know people are
generation millennials and stuff they
would love to enjoy their job they would
love to have work that feels energizing
but in a way they don't know what the
roadmap is to actually doing that beyond
quit your job and follow your passion
and i think there are lots of things you
can do you can apply to a job to make it
make it actually become more energizing
so like themes of more empowerment
control
personal
i don't know yeah personal control over
how you use your energy how you're
spending your energy how you control
your own work that kind of thing yeah
control is certainly certainly part of
it um you know in our section one we're
going to talk about like the four
the four kind of streams of renewable
energy that you find in work and you
that you can tap into to recharge your
energies um you know one of those is
power so the idea of like autonomy the
idea of
um responsibility the idea of like
sort of understanding and taking
ownership and understanding how things
work we're still trying to figure out
the exact terminology behind it that's
the challenge right now over these next
few weeks to basically bullet point
outline every single chapter we kind of
know like roughly what is the thesis of
each chapter what are the what are the
strategies and now we're doing a whole
deep dive into the research to make sure
that like a there's sufficient
scientific evidence to back this up and
if there isn't then well we changed the
piece
yeah and you mentioned you want this to
be one of
more books yeah i like the idea of
writing more books to me like it's it's
one of those things where
you know there's a chap called ryan
holliday who you i'm sure have heard of
he's written a bunch of books over here
he seems to have a pretty solid
lifestyle he wakes up he lives on a farm
in like near austin texas i think he
wakes up
goes for a walk he goes into his study
he reads and writes her for about four
hours and then from lunchtime onwards he
hangs out with his kids and like does
stuff in nature and things like that and
every every year or two he bangs out a
book and books are really good and there
are sort of stoicism type books and that
introduced the ideas from like seneca
and marcus aurelius and stuff to a
mainstream audience seems like a pretty
good lifestyle and i can imagine like
the longevity of being an author being
far greater than the longevity of being
a quick youtuber if you had to choose
receiver 2
what would you choose
if i could be an author forever or a
youtuber
write it or make videos let's make it
broader i feel okay so i think i am
like i i have a bit of an unfair
question but so yeah so i i have no
personal horse in this race okay in that
for me
teaching is the ultimate one yeah um
whether that teaching is best done and
best meaning it's fun and it's
profitable and it's useful to other
people whether that's best done through
writing books or through writing
articles writing tweets or making videos
or doing it in real life i'm fairly
agnostic about those things i really do
enjoy teaching in real life so i always
want some element of like in-person
interaction to be part of my thing
whether i make a video or whether i
write
i don't really care right now the video
thing is way more profitable but the
writing thing is sort of like a slow
burn over time
okay
so the book january 2024
fingers crossed yeah in in between that
in terms of the business side of things
we're launching this new brand hopefully
in the next month or so creatorpreneur
are there any other aspects that you see
kind of developing over the next 18
months um that we can sort of talk about
now
aspects of the business it's gonna grow
at all yeah so i think
right now everything we do is pretty
okay
um but there are ways to consolidate and
systemize and make it better yeah so
that's what i see is sort of the job for
this year like how do we now that we
have this team of 18 people potentially
even hiring hiring a few more to fill
more holes how do we then approach make
it so that everyone is rowing in the
same direction right now
we're sort of directionally going the
same direction but actually this i think
this is kind of a failing on mine and
your part in that we have not kind of
done the four obsessions of an
extraordinary executive as per pat
lencioni's book of communicating a sort
of creating organizational clarity over
communicating organizational clarity and
creating people systems to reinforce
organizational clarity i think the job
for this year is to basically get our
house in order consolidate make sure our
systems and processes and like people
all know what they're doing so that we
can
systematically create decent youtube
videos and decent courses and decent
like
the website articles and podcast
episodes and stuff like the more
systemized we can make the whole thing
the kind of safer it becomes and the
less i hopefully need to be involved in
like shaping things with a heavy hand
and actually giving autonomy to more of
the team members to shape their projects
however they want providers in line with
the core values of the business and the
tone and the branding and all that kind
of stuff
um i think one area that we want to do a
lot in is just making more courses i
think right now most of our revenue
comes from courses it comes from our
youtuber academy and it comes from
skillshare uh 20 of it roughly comes
from youtube channel in terms of brand
deals and adsense and
basically the podcast just about breaks
even at this point maybe is slightly
profitable
so i think we can increase our revenues
and our profits by creating more
pre-recorded courses
because right now it's like you know
nearly three million subscribers on the
youtube channel loads of people
listening to this podcast but there's
not a lot that we do to monetize it
actually no like despite the fact that
we're probably gonna make five million
this year with like maybe three million
profit or something like that they're
still we're still leaving so much money
on the table in terms of the
monetization angle and so i think if we
can just churn out maybe a really good
course every quarter now we have our own
products that we can send people to
rather than necessarily relying on brand
deals that this podcast is brought to
you by brilliant great i mean brilliant
fantastic but like if we can plug if we
can send enough customers over to
brilliant to warrant them paying us
however much they pay us which i don't
think i'm allowed to share we can
probably send customers to our own thing
yeah and so we kind of own more of that
customer journey so i think it's that
monetizing on the back end that we
currently are under monetized in and so
can we make more courses that are really
good so that in the future
we can just turn our attentions to just
be like all right great now now we we're
making enough money from courses on the
back end now we know that every time we
make a youtube video you know maybe 0.01
of that audience will convert to a
course but actually that's more than
enough to fund the continuing production
of the youtube videos and we create
almost this sort of
infinite machine whereby we're putting
all of our effort into making free
content and by default it's making money
because some people are buying the
courses
i think it's that second bit of it right
now that is a little bit under
under levered and i'd like to work on
that yeah because i think it's it's gone
through various different stages isn't
it because when i joined the main
revenue was coming from
kind of small-scale brand deals because
you just joined an agency yeah
then this kind of skillshare started to
take off yep and when that was becoming
so big we thought well i need to do
something else then p2a happened yep and
now that's come to a certain position
and now i think yeah we're at a stage
where
the pre-recorded courses are probably
the way forward in terms of both the
effort for for you and the time that you
have as well as the effectiveness in
terms of their kind of evergreen nature
and recurring revenue aspect one other
thing that
we we launched earlier this year in
january was that the stationary brand
what what part does physical merchandise
have in
how you see the future of the business
i like the idea of physical merchandise
but i know it's outside of our core
focus another thing that we're really
good at is creating educational content
the thing we're not really good at is
creating physical merchandise and
shipping it and like dealing with
printing and logistics and manufacturing
and customer service and all that crap
that's associated with physical products
but at the same time it's really cool to
make physical products yeah so i think
you know
the the way i think of it it's it's sort
of like a side quest our main quest line
is the content but every now and then
we'll do a side quest of it would be
cool to make our own statement brand
just because it's cool it would be cool
to make our own mechanical keyboard
because why not it would be really cool
to make our own bag maybe partner with a
company like peak design or something to
make our own back because why the hell
not that would be really cool um if any
mechanical keyboard
companies or bad companies are listening
please do get in touch yeah um that
would be the dream i you know i've got
peter mckinnon's backpack that he made
in collaboration with nomatic that seems
really cool it would be great to do some
something like that with some kind of
bad company who have expertise in making
the thing yeah i think there's one thing
i've realized is that it's actually
really hard to do something well
and the thing that we do well is content
and if we try and over index and like oh
well we can do content therefore we can
also make a keyboard it's like no
probably not we should probably try to
work with a company to make that happen
and apply our own you know maybe we can
help input on the design like i have
pretty strong opinions about keyboards
and about bags and what a good what a
good bag should have but we certainly
don't want to be trying too hard to
manufacture things in the house for
example that makes sense it makes sense
i i think the stationary looks great and
has done has done reasonably well but i
think it is it is a bit of a sidequest
as well in terms of the the effort
required and the capacity and resources
required as well for it is different to
what we've got currently available but
even if we have the capacity even if we
hire
we could for example say let's hire a
full-time person to just make it right
it's a core focus thing yeah it's a cool
thing it's outside of our core focus
therefore we probably shouldn't do it
too much
in terms of other in terms of those
courses that we are developing at the
moment
we've also got the criterpreneur one
coming out in a month or so time how how
do you see that developing at the moment
how happy are you with that i think
they're absolutely sick i think a lot of
the stuff we put on skillshare as well
is really good we recently released a
youtube for beginners course on
skillshare which i think is like way
in a way almost too good for skillshare
because it is a course that we probably
could have sold for several hundred
dollars ourselves but we decided oh
let's put it on skillshare so more
people can access it for free because
why not
link in the video description or in the
show notes if everyone wants to check
that one out so i just really like
putting courses together especially if
it's a topic that i'm very familiar with
and so this creatorpreneur stuff
basically teaching creators how to think
more like entrepreneurs like business
owners
basically sort of uh
combining everything that you and i have
learned about this business stuff over
the last two years into a course that
felt really cool and it's been amazing
to see for example gordon and sean and
gareth and the people managing you know
helping out with the creative printer
project that like
i can show up for the initial phases and
to
deliver the content and then the backend
of it is taken care of where like the
videography is sick the editing is sick
the landing page is sick the marketing
funnels are sick like all of those
things are things that
i am personally a not an expert in and
don't necessarily want to spend my time
worrying about because i want to spend
my time teaching
and in the past when making courses
those things would detract from the time
that i've got available to teach whereas
now i can just rock up and teach and
then all the other stuff is taken care
of so that feels enormously exciting and
i'm very excited to see how this project
comes together because i guess it's our
first real course product that we've put
together
where
it's been owned by someone else and i
have basically just rocked up for the
writing component and for the talking to
camera component
so
going back to one of my initial
questions is this what you expected
i'm not really sure i had expectations
i was kind of like uh we'll try this out
and see how it goes
um
i think
but i guess what i'm doing is it's like
the the business whereby
you can turn up
do your thing and everything else all
the other bits all the filming and
everything yeah it's dealt with by
someone else yeah that was a dream and i
think we're fairly close to
fairly close to that dream i still feel
like i get probably too involved in some
stuff
but also i think there is a risk of
and maybe this is one of the mistakes i
made earlier on of just being like hey
amber we want to launch a podcast to go
and just being like cool whatevs
but actually like one thing i realized
over time is that there probably needs
to be some level of direction from me
some level of vision of like what do we
actually want this to be otherwise then
amber who produces that podcast and does
a fantastic job it's like kind of folk
going on going down one line because she
thinks that's the right thing to do and
then i see and i was like oh actually
let's change my mind and then she's
wasted like two months away at work so
there's a lot that i should do in
setting out the vision
more clearly and then i'll happily leave
it to you and the team to execute on
that okay just talk about business stuff
and business vision and that kind of
thing but in terms of like
personal side of things how how are you
how are things going are you content
with where you are in in life more
broadly yeah genuinely i honestly can't
imagine being any happier but that's
sort of the thought that i've had for
the last several years of my life okay i
think beyond my first year of university
every year felt like it was better than
the last and when asked or when i would
check in with myself of how how content
i am with life am i with life it would
just probably be a 10 out of 10. um i
think i'm very lucky in that i haven't
really experienced any profound setbacks
any major like life difficulties any
major like mental health issues so
enormously grateful for that and i think
also like part of the you know the
benefit of having like coaches and stuff
there's a chap called corey who i work
with um each week we just hop in a
little coaching call and like the thing
with it's like like business coaching
ends up basically being therapy yeah
it's like what's what's on your mind
that you're struggling with well i'm not
really sure about our organizational
chart design all right cool let's let's
talk it through or i'm not really sure
if we're if we're maybe doing too many
things in the business okay let's talk
it through i'm not really sure if like i
really enjoy showing up to 20 hours a
week of youtuber academy live events
okay let's talk it through and just
having someone as a sort of impartial
third party to talk it through from a
sort of business bro perspective i think
has been helpful for me to figure out
like
any time
i sort of find myself looking at my
calendar and thinking ugh then i think
okay that's a sign that the thing that i
maybe
the way my calendar looks is actually
not in alignment with the way with the
way i want to live my life and so what
can i do about that and i'm very lucky
now that i am in a place where i can
just do what i want
and if there is something on the
calendar that i don't like i can just
say okay this is we we need to change
this
whereas a lot of people are not in that
position and that's partly why i'm so
bullish on people you know
building multiple streams of income and
stuff because if you are reliant on a
single source of income i.e your job for
you know survival
it does limit your autonomy it doesn't
limit your ability to potentially live
your best life
unless you happen to be working in this
team of course because everyone has a
great time although not necessarily ever
as opposed by the employee survey
yeah um things we need to work on i
think we need to work on yeah um but
yeah probably ten out of ten contentment
loving life and and living in london
living in cambridge for six five years
six years nine years no no yeah of
course yeah i'm i'm working on my my
time there um nine years yeah how is
living in london i love living in london
london is great like i think it's less
about london itself and more about the
fact that it's so central and like
people are around london so there's
always people coming through london
there's almost never people coming
through cambridge there's always always
friends around like if i ever have a
free evening and i want to hang out with
people i just need to text people be
like hey do you want to grab dinner or
do you want to come over to mine for a
gym session or a spa session or a
takeaway and people will be like yeah
sure so that's the really cool thing
about london
um
yeah so i think i definitely want to be
here next year as well and then beyond
that who knows um maybe you want to
travel the world at some point but
you know
i try not to plan too far ahead just
because life changes yes okay on that
point though the the traveling aspect
has always been something that you've
mentioned
in various videos as people know about
the moving to america not within america
um and other times you've mentioned it
is that a long-term ambition to travel
or is it just kind of a
thought that you might want to do at
some point in the future yeah it's a
thought that i might want to do it at
some point in the future and the thought
that like everyone i know who's ever
done extended travel has said it's been
really helpful and interesting and
useful and just like good life
experience and so yeah while i'm young
and relatively uncomfortable without
kids at a mortgage and stuff although
actually we do have more um
yeah relatively unencumbered without
without kids it feels like a good time
to at least try out that kind of style
of living that kind of adventure
but then again there was this chap i
spoke to who was one of our students on
our youtuber academy who's like a doctor
who left medicine and is now traveling
the world with his wife and three kids
and is currently living in cape town so
i mean it's certainly possible later in
life but i think it's a cool experiment
to try out earlier in life as well
wrapping up and thinking more about this
podcast specifically do you have any
regrets about starting this podcast nope
not at all not at all what what have
what's like the number one lesson that
you've taken from
the very first interview that i guess we
might have recorded back in may of last
year yeah with um the founder of must
match i'm forgetting his name uh shazad
yeah and then we did ben francis yeah
you're old flat
over that sort of 11 months what's kind
of the number one thing you've taken
from meeting people or what have you
gained from talking to all these people
yeah i think um
it's just been fun i just enjoy having
conversations
with people i think b
it's helped me realize that like no one
really knows what they're doing and
everyone's just trying trying their best
and making it up as they go along which
is cool i think in a previous life i
would have ca actually no that's
probably
i was going to say i would have cared
about like actionable life advice and i
still do i still really do care about
actionable life advice like if ben
francis or james softman or julie smith
or anyone tells me something where i
think oh crap i don't know that i'm
gonna i'm gonna start using that right
now
uh it's been good in terms of
actually you know when i'm interviewing
people i get to ask them the questions
that i want to know the answer to you
know for example when talking to james
hoffman it's like what's actually like
making a coffee shop i have this vague
dream in my mind oh i'd love to have a
coffee shop someday is it fun he's like
oh god no it's not fun at all oh that's
interesting you know i'm learning
something that i didn't know otherwise
so i kind of view the conversations as a
making friends b just having vibes in a
conversation and see
basically being able to talk to someone
at length about something that i'm
interested in them about like what their
journey was like to you know judy smith
for example like you know quitting her
job as a psychologist to become a tick
tocker that's a bit random let's talk
about that yeah i think it's
it's been fun where do you see it going
now obviously season three is starting
in a few weeks do you see it just
continuing season by season and
where'd you see it building to like who
is your dream guest do you not have a
dream guest
ah there's a whole dream guest thing
it's all very like you have a list of
people that you would want to interview
yeah it's it's all very outcome outcome
focused and i don't really like thinking
about outcomes but
i do have a again you know someone like
darren brown would be on my dream guest
list someone like alana bottom would be
on my dream guest list probably those
two tim ferriss at some point might be
cool but also you know they say don't
meet your heroes so i you know if i if i
never end up talking to tim ferriss it's
not it's not a major loss for either him
or me um i think like the the way i
approach all of these things is really
just like focusing as much as i possibly
can on what can i do that's within my
control yeah
and
having even the idea of having like a
dream guest just to me feel yeah
like i don't i don't really have a dream
guest
but it would be nice to be darren brown
at some point talking of things within
my control i can control when this
interview ends and so i think we'll
bring it to an end here
it's been good to talk about uh the
business and things moving forward i'm
sure there'll probably be other videos
on the main youtube channel at some
point giving a broader life update yeah
we've been a few months since we last
did one we need to figure out that
series like backstage or behind the
scenes yeah something yeah but we are
starting with just a quick final thing
we are starting a daily vlog right on
the second channel yeah i think so you
think so as of the second of may yeah
we'll see what that looks like yeah and
yeah um
final thing i guess is just wanna kind
of
shout you out publicly for all of the
all of the stuff that you do for this
business like it's just pretty freaking
mental that like i think it was almost
two or two years ago now yeah every two
years again two years ago you cold
emailed me thing like hey do you need a
random writer for some of your videos i
was like yeah and now you have kind of
ascended the ranks as it were and
basically created the ranks
uh over the last two years to the point
that you're the general manager of the
entire business yeah and you really do
kind of keep the trains running on time
and make sure things things are getting
done
and that really frees me up to do the
things that i love so
thank you for allowing me to live my
best life
through the fact that you do all of the
stuff that i don't want to take
and i can do it really well yes no thank
you yeah well it's been it's been fun
it's been fun like it's weird to think
that that was like before the pandemic
and that's like there was a time before
the pandemic um but yeah no it's been
good especially like ptya that's kind of
probably been the most gratifying thing
that i think we've done together because
that started with just like sticky notes
on the floor of the old flat and now
it's this sort of the him off of a
course
um
so yeah but yeah it's been good
excellent nice good stuff let's wrap it
there wonderful all right so that's it
for this week's episode of deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye